yat monde sarkozy c'est quoi ce bordel
on se retrouve pour les résultats que
vous attendez temps du concours spécial
180 abonnés alors la pub va être comme
ça devant vos écrans enfin aux hôtes
cheese fusain ou comme ça je vais pas
gagner je veux gagner à gagner et je
vous présente vraiment toutes mes
excuses pour avoir applaudi les
résultats si tard
je dois vous avouer que j'ai quand même
eu pas mal d'imprévus bref dans tous les
cas l'important c'est que vous ayez des
résultats qu'on met les noms des sept
gagnants dont qu'il y avait je rappelle
troisième ce cas de charge de gagner
trois jeux bref juste avant de vous
donner le nom des gagnants est ce qu'ils
ont gagné je voulais juste vous dire que
les prochains concours seront annoncés
bien à l'avancé sur twitter et y en aura
sûrement des concours plus petits avec
moins de grosses chutes de grosses
choses à gagner pardon mais qui seront
données que sur twitter c'est à dire je
mettrais dire non répertorié que ce sera
pas visée sur ma chaîne youtube mais que
vous pourrez le voir quels sur twitter
le lien donc je vous invite vraiment un
monsieur sur twitter c'est dans la
description c'est pas une blague cette
fois je veux vraiment faire il y aura
des choses à gagner comme des points
microsoft sûrement souvent peut-être
aussi des fois un concours eu droit à un
jeu et plusieurs cars points microsoft
et on aura un peu plus que ces sortes de
gros concours parce qu'il y aura moins
de trucs à gagner tout simplement il y
aura quand même des choses à gagner donc
c'est assez vrai plaisir en tout cas
seuls ceux qui me suivent sur twitter
seront au courant donc venez me
rejoindre sur twitter c'est dans la
description là on passe maintenant au
tirage au sort des gagnants
le premier gagnant et ce jeu mythique
sky année cap 1200 points microsoft
c'est ce qu'il voulait c'est ce que
j'avais tant mieux vais pas me baigner
le le deuxième gagnant et tu te mets
fixe qui avaient participé pour un game
capture hd
il est à devoir félicitations le
troisième gagnant et vd à 1974 qui avait
participé pour un game capture hd ou
pour borderlands 2 il reste encore deux
games capture hd à gagner donc je te
donne le meilleur look est donc le guen
capture hd et bats-toi le 4ème gagnants
de notre concours et tétanise qui
avaient participé pour un battlefield 3
premières sur pc eh bien tu as gagné
l'est désormais à toi aussi le cinquième
gagnant les marques aux pumas qui
avaient participé pour un game capture
hd ou fifa xiii sur ps3 il reste encore
un game capture hd a gagné il est donc à
toi puisque tu es tirés au sort avant
ont peut-être des gens
j'ai tiré au sort qui aura là donc et
bien bravo le sixième gagnon les yeux 30
donc comme je l'avais dit c'était sûr
que des gens allaient encore demandé des
iem capture hd
bon heureusement ce seront 10 7 a dit
que sinon ils voulaient un battlefield 3
pc donc tu gagnes un battlefield 3 pc
j'espère que ça fera quand même plaisir
je suis désolé mais c'est la chance y en
a comme nom il y en a comme moi il y en
a qui n'ont pas et notre septième et
dernier gagnant et yoyo 02 01 97 qui
avaient participé pour un fifa xiii sur
ps3 bravo à toi
il est at war donc voilà les résultats
du concours sont déjà terminées merci à
toutes et à tous d'avoir participé et
d'être déjà près de 220 milles à me
suivre sur ma chaîne youtube c'est tout
simplement énorme je ferai d'autres
concours et notamment deux comme les
gens des vidéos qui seront annoncées
uniquement sur twitter mais qui seront
plus petit bravo le set gagnant merci
vraiment d'avoir participé l'essentiel
va c'est d'avoir tenté en tout cas et
puis j'espère vous gagnerez peut-être
une prochaine fois et je peux pas faire
gagner deux sont mis de l'eau ça serait
dur à voir si je vais gagner ce cheveu
que je n'ai pas réussi à m'arracher je
m'excuse aussi pour cette voie de merde
que j'ai je vais pas pouvoir faire des
vidéos pendant trois quatre jours mais
je vous préviens quand même des trucs
vraiment cool vous inquiétez pas et au
pire j'en ferai quand même une comme à
l'époque où j'avais fait une vidéo
survolt en mode voldemort pardon et
c'était un peu la merde je suis malade
oui vous ça peut se voir la tronche à
m'avoir mon bref c'est une catastrophe
or on se retrouve bientôt dans une
nouvelle vidéo je vous laisse sur ma
dernière vidéo
à bientôt de monde ciao ps jean drapeau
le genre
vous devez tout ça pas